let's bring you more on the latest
infection numbers and the number of
people who have died
of coronavirus in the uk in the last 24
hours emma berkshire is in
the newsroom has been having a look at
the figures for us emma
yes and the most shocking thing actually
is the number of people
who have died so that figure has been
put
at 1610 it's the highest
number that we have seen
throughout this pandemic in this country
and significantly higher than yesterday
where the figure was 599
a better comparison is actually to look
weak on weeks so if we look at last
tuesday
the figure was 1243 so an increase
of not far off 400 on last week
also when we look at the number of
people who have tested positive
in the past 24 hours that figure put it
33
355. now that's actually down
on 37.5 000 yesterday and 12
000 down on this time last week which is
once again the much more useful
comparison looking week on week
and that has to be a good sign you would
hope
because of course if you've got fewer
people testing positive that means
fewer people ultimately ending up in
hospital and very sadly then
losing their lives we have also the
figure
of how many people have had their first
dose
of the vaccination so that's 4.27
million people up from 4.06
million people yesterday actually
there's a slight slowing down in the
rate that they appear to be vaccinating
at the moment we were seeing
300 000 a day this is more like um
200 000 sorry yeah 200 000
but still you know this is an enormous
task but i think the headline of these
really dreadful figures is that
1 610 people
in these latest figures who've lost
their lives within 28 days of a positive
test